So there's a new
Wikipedia article for the crisis
happening in the Red Sea.
Let’s look at the map.
This is the Red Sea.
It's where
tens of thousands of merchant ships
travel through
to keep our global economy running.
Lately, rebels in Yemen
have been firing missiles
and drones at these cargo ships.
You can see
all of these attacks here right
at this choke point
where Yemen and Djibouti come together.
So far,
the rebels have hit like
ten of these cargo ships.
And they say they're doing it
to punish Israel and its backers
for this war that's happening in Gaza.
This is a nightmare
for shipping companies
who are now having to reroute their ships
to much longer routes.
And it's causing all these price issues
and it's not good.
This, waterway is very critical
to the global economy.
So the U.S. and U.K.
and other countries are sending
in their navies,
intercepting these attacks
and trying to stabilize
this vital waterway.
This waterway affects all of us
because we are all attached
to the global economy,
whether we like it or not.
So I’m going to keep an eye on this.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.